The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM GREEN JR:
All right today, I
would like to do a Kinetic Monte
Carlo example with you in class
and, also, talk a little
bit about the connection
between the master equations,
master equation solution,
the normal kinetic
equations we use, and the--
how you handle
these trajectories,
you'll get how to
Kinetic Monte Carlo.
All right, so let's just
pick a simple example.
As we mentioned,
in the real world,
it's pretty easy
for these examples
to get completely out of
hand, because the number
of possible states
can be so gigantic.
Let's all do a really super,
super simple one here.
To try to keep that underhand,
not worry about that.
When you do the real problems,
that will be a major issue--
is if he number of
states get out of hand.
So the simple
example I'm gonna do
is a real one from
inside your body.
So inside your body,
you have a thing
called low density lipoprotein.
And there's little vesicles of
fat, lipids, inside your body,
actually, in your blood vessels.
And these are bad.
If you go to the doctor, they
measure your LDL and your HDL.
And if your LDL
number is too high
then they yell at you for
eating too much fat food.
And they make you exercise
and stuff like that.
This has happened
to me, so I know.
And there's a reason for
this, is because the LDL is
susceptible to oxidation.
And if too many of those
lipid molecules peroxidize,
it causes inflammation
in your blood vessels.
And that can cause
your blood vessels
to constrict and
stuff that eventually
can lead to heart attacks.
And so that's why
your doctor is alarmed
if you have too much
LDL, because you have
a lot more material available
that could be oxidized,
that could kill you.
There's actually a really
complicated, interesting story
about what vitamin
E does in the LDL,
and how it interacts
with vitamin C.
And if you take
my kinetics class,
I'll tell you about that.
But we'll do the
simplest case now.
There's no vitamin E, there's
nobody Vitamin C. You just have
some lipid, and it's oxidizing.
And let's model
what's happening.
So what you have is a
little bubble of fat.
So out here is water.
And here's my fat which
I'll politely call lipid.
That sounds like not quite
as fat, if you call it lipid,
slimy.
And the lipid is susceptible
to attack by this reaction.
So if I have some
peroxy radical,
and I have the lipid molecules,
which are some hydrocarbon,
they can react and make
peroxide plus a radical.
And in your blood
vessels, if you're not
under the water or being killed,
you have a lot of oxygen.
And so the carbon
set of radicals
you form immediately
react with oxygen
to make the peroxy radical back.
And so the net process--
we can kind of
combine these steps,
because this is super fast.
So it's like a
microsecond times scale.
For that to happen in your
body, because the oxygen
concentration is so
high in the blood.
And so this reaction is
really roo, plus RAH, plus O2,
to rooh, plus roo.
So the radical is
just catalyzing
the oxidation of your
lipid into the peroxide.
When this level gets too high,
then your body will detect it.
There's an inflation, and you'll
have all kinds of trouble.
OK, so we like to
understand this.
Now, these vesicles
are very small,
so there's a
probability you might
have only a very, very, small
number of radicals in there.
Also, your body has
a lot of antioxidants
in it, like vitamin C and
vitamin E and some other ones
too.
And the antioxidants are
trying to get rid of radicals.
So the number of radicals you'd
expect the concentration--
background concentration
is very tiny.
And because of
that, this is tiny
and the concentration is tiny.
So the concentration times
the volume might also be tiny.
So the total number of radicals
might be very, very small.
And so therefore, you
might need to worry
about the stochastic
kinetics being
different than the
continuum kinetics.
OK, so that's the idea.
Now, on top of that,
you also have a lot
of these vesicles in your body.
So you might be able to somehow
work up some continuum model,
treat them all.
And in fact, I think that's
what people did originally, is
they just said well, let's take
the total amount of LDL you
got in your body and
do a continuum model.
But as you will
see, it's different,
because the fact that
the vesicles are small,
each one might only have,
say, one radical in it.
And that will actually
behave quite differently than
if you had a lot of radicals.
All right so, this
is the kinetics,
and the oxygen is almost
always high concentration,
so I'm not going to
worry about that.
And I'm going to assume that
we're not going let your lipid
oxidize so much that the amount
of lipid changes significantly.
So let's just, for now,
we can just ignore this.
OK, maybe later we might
go back and figure out
how you'd account for the
fact that these cells are
being consumed, which would
change the rates a little bit.
So we'll just assume that
concentration is constant.
So you have a tiny
amount of radicals.
And if you had the
radicals in your vesicle,
they're creating roh.
And you see, the
ro is catalytic.
And so what we're
gonna see is basically
D. If you did it in
classical kinetics,
you'd write DR dt
this is basically
equals some constant times roo.
And then, I lumped
these concentrations
into this constant.
[INAUDIBLE] That all right?
All right, so that's
the import process.
We also have another
important process,
is that if you get
two radicals in there,
and they bump into each other,
they can kill each other off.
So two peroxy radicals
can combine and make
stable molecules.
And we don't care what stable
molecules they really are.
What's important is that
they get rid of the radicals,
because the radicals
are catalyzing
the unfavorable oxidation.
In this program I started
writing, I called this k3.
This one is k4, reaction four.
There's two other
things happening.
Out here, I had some
peroxy radicals.
They're floating
around the water.
Some of them might
go into my lipid.
I'll call that process K1.
There's some time constant,
which new radicals arrive.
And then, I also
have the possibility
these guys could diffuse out.
So I call that k2.
And k1, I'll just
treat as a constant.
So as soon as a background
concentration radicals
that's constant, and so this
is a sum-- every 10 seconds
or something, a radical
arrives in a vesicle.
And this will depend
on the concentration,
the number of ro's.
So the more you have
inside here, the faster
the rate which they go out.
That all right?
And this just mass transfer.
But from the point of
view of the equations,
it doesn't care if it's mass
transfer or chemical reaction.
They arrive in the same way.
All right, so that's the system.
And so let's look at the--
I should try to write
the MATLAB code for this.
And maybe, we can try to
finish this together in class.
So I have four processes--
arrival of new
radical, diffusion
of the radical and
the vesicle, reaction
to make the peroxide,
and self-destruction
of the radicals.
And I wrote down what
each of these does.
So the first one increases
the number of radicals by one.
The second one gets
rid of a radical
because it's diffused away.
The third one increases
the amount of peroxide.
The last one gets
rid of two radicals.
So we're going to try to compute
a trajectory by the Kinetic
Monte Carlo method.
And trajectory is
going to be some time
points, the number of
radicals at that time
point, the number of peroxides
I have at that time point.
And as I run, I'm going to
get many, many, different time
points.
And each one will have a
different number of radicals
or a different
number of peroxides.
And that's what I
want to compute.
And then, at the end, after I
have trajectories like that,
big tables of these things, I
want to somehow put it together
to figure out on average
what happened or something,
try to understand it.
And so let's see, so my
inputs are the initial numbers
of radicals and peroxides in
the vesicle, the vector of rate
coefficients, the max
amount of time I want
to run the trajectory for--
not clock time, but
time in the simulation.
So it's like how many
microseconds or milliseconds
or seconds I look
at my lipid protein
and see what it's doing.
And the maximum number
of steps, because I
don't want to get a
trajectory list that's
10 to the ninth long, because
over a while, my memory,
my computer would
cause me trouble.
So here they are,
all the setups.
Everything is fine so far.
So here's the loop.
So the outermost loop is just
to keep track of how many steps
we have, which is going to
be the number of entries we
have in the trajectory table.
And the second one is really--
what we care about--
is well, the time
is less than the maximum
time of the simulation.
First, we want to figure
out the time [INAUDIBLE]
until something happens.
So following Joe
Scott's notes, we
compute this quantity
called A, which
is the sum of all the rates.
And that's equal to the
rate of the first process.
And then, they're in the
second process, which depends
on the number of radicals.
And the rate of
the third process
all depends on the radicals.
And the rate of
the fourth process,
which is a number radicals
times the number of radicals
minus one.
Now k4 has to have
units of per second.
But bi-molecular rates would
normally have units of volume
per second, per mole even--
volume is per
molecule per second.
And so that k4 has to
really be a normal kind
of k divided by the volume.
And we're going to
have to figure out what
to do about that in a minute.
And then, we do the
formula to get the--
Gillespie's formula
for how to sample
from an exponential
decay, as good as that is.
So Gillespie thinks that the
probability that something
is going to happen, or
the probability, the time,
until the next thing
happens is going as e
to the negative a times t.
So we're trying to sample
from e to the negative, a, t.
And that's what that crazy log
of the random number is doing--
it's sampling from
that distribution.
And so we get a [INAUDIBLE]
that how long we've
waited from the time
the last thing happened
until the next thing happened.
And now, we have to
figure what happened.
So there's four
different processes
that could have happened.
A radical could have arrived.
A radical could have left.
A radical could have reacted
with one of my hydrocarbon
molecules, with
one of my lipids,
or the two radicals could
have killed each other.
So we list these guys out.
A is the sum of all
those processes.
P1 is the probability that
the first process happened,
that a new radical arrives.
So it's going to be the k for
the first step, divided by a.
That one was zero
water, because it's
subterfuging it from outside.
So it's just a k of 1.
Probably the second
step is k2 times n rad.
That's the rate of the second
step divided by the total rate
of all the processes.
And I'm going to
add that onto p1
to make a vector of possible
things that could happen.
So I'm picking a random
number from zero to one.
And I want to make a little bar.
Here's the probability the
first process happened.
And here's the probability that
the second process happened.
And here's the probability
the third process happened.
the fourth process happened.
I know that these guys
have to add up to one,
because I computed that
something happened.
And so I'm going to try to
compare my random number
from zero to one to these breaks
and sort it out into these four
possibilities, and then figure
out which thing happened.
OK, so this is the second
step of Gillespie's algorithm.
All right, so maybe you guys can
help me finish the code here.
If you want to go to Broadway
in Chicago, you can go there.
So I need to write the next one.
So p3 is equal p2 plus what?
So step three is--
sorry?
Say again.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: All
right, that's enough, right?
So now, I get to
choose a random number,
so, say, x is equal to rand.
And then, I have to say if x is
less than p1, than something.
What's it gonna be?
Then step number one happened.
So that means that n rad
is equal to n rad plus one,
so one radical transported in.
If x is less than p2--
[INAUDIBLE] Is that good?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR:
[INAUDIBLE] space.
Thank you.
What happens here?
So this is b, n rad is
equal to n rad minus one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: I think they
also take care of that, right?
Is this right?
X is less than p3, than nroh.
Else and rand.
Does that look right?
Do I need an end?
AUDIENCE: Semi-colon.
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Semi-colon.
Semi-colon, thank you.
That would be really bad.
All right, yes, Ziggy?
AUDIENCE: So in
the first problem,
you have step size longer
than that [INAUDIBLE] size.
WILLIAM GREEN JR:
So that's not good.
It should be less than.
Thank you.
Any more bugs?
AUDIENCE: I think you need
spaces after the brackets.
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Spaces
after the brackets-- where?
Is that here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR:
[INAUDIBLE] separate line.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: I can do that.
It's easier to read anyway.
So that's good.
I definitely agree with that.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Is that right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM GREEN JR: You like this?
With all these [INAUDIBLE]
sets, I don't need any n's, is
that right?
[INAUDIBLE] after the other
like that, no problem.
Just one end at the end.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: That's good.
All right, so
we're OK with this?
We think this is going to work?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM GREEN JR:
All right, so now,
we've computed what's
going to happen.
Now, we need to store
results somehow.
So I'm gonna say
trajectory is equal to--
or trajectory of steps--
so step was zeros.
Now, step is one.
[INAUDIBLE] step is
one, to start with.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM GREEN JR:
Does this look good?
They had only commas,
is that right?
No commas?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: All
right, one step is zero.
I already have the first
line filled in here.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Is that good?
We'll see.
I don't know if it's OK or
not, but I'll believe you.
All right, so right
now, we have a program
that maybe or maybe not might
actually compute something.
Is that right?
OK, now, we to figure out--
are we going to
run this program?
So we need an initial.
So any suggestions?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: All right,
so let's do an initial--
how about n rad is equal to
1 and nroh is equal to 0.
Is that OK?
We're cool with that?
And how about k?
So we need a vector of k's.
Yup?
AUDIENCE: For your
line 18, I think
that's just the [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR:
Yes, thank you.
Yes?
All right, so let's think about
what's reasonable for the k's.
So I think we can make the
k for this stuff diffusing
in very, very small.
So I don't know--
[INAUDIBLE] make a small,
1e minus 5 something.
Isn't that small--
only once an hour.
You think it might be
a little too small?
And then, the next one is how
fast do things diffuse out?
Now, what's that going
to physically depend on?
It should be something
like the diffusion.
Diffusion [INAUDIBLE]
get back to the wall,
back to the outside.
So it should be--
by one radical in here,
what's the average time for it
to diffuse back out?
Any ideas?
So if it does, say, just
a random walk, maybe--
then you say that delta x
squared is like d times tt.
OK, so delta x
squared, maybe make
this like the radius
of our lipid vesicle,
so that delta t is
like r squared over d.
Seems like a reasonable scaling.
And we actually want to rate,
so we want the other way around.
So k2 is going to be something
like d over r squared.
All right, so we need to pick
a size of our LDL vesicles.
I don't actually
know what they are.
I used to know this,
but I don't remember.
Anybody want to
make a guess, how
big is a vesicle inside
your blood vessel?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Micron.
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Micron, OK.
So let's pick a mircron.
So let's say r is equal to
10 to the minus 6 meters.
What's a diffusion
constant in liquid phase?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: [INAUDIBLE]
meter squared per second.
OK, so feasible.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Anybody
know if it's meter squared
or centimeter squared?
What?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: You guys
did the one of the drug.
What was the drugs one?
Was it 10 to the minus 6, meter
squared or centimeter squared?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM GREEN JR:
Meters squared.
OK, so for a light, smaller
molecule, it's reasonable.
So this number should
be something like 10
to the minus 5, divided
by 10 to the minus 12,
so something like 10 to the 7.
1, 8, and 7.
All right, now for the
reaction, roo plus RH,
we can go look it up
on the [INAUDIBLE]..
They'll have a list of
reactions like that.
For now, let's just guess.
And so let's say that k3--
k of roo plus rh--
these guys typically
have 8 factors of 10
to the eighth leaders
per mole second.
And they have ea's, about 15--
15 k cals per mole over rt.
OK so now, we need to
figure out how to turn this
into the k3 we want.
Now, the k3 we want is really--
K3 is like this--
times the concentration
of the rh,
because we took the
rh out of the problem,
because we want this to
have units of per second.
Is that right?
And this is in units
of volume per meters
cubed per mole second.
And this would be
moles per meter cubed.
And so it's per second,
which looks right.
OK so now, we need to have--
I understand we
have a calculator?
We can try to calculate this
number for room temperature.
And this does not mean room
temperature is r time t--
actually for body temperature.
And the concentration
of hydrocarbon--
it's actually the number
of h's, because every h can
be attacked in a hydrocarbon.
So you typically have
densities of 0.8 grams
per centimeter cubed.
It's for organic.
And you typically
have two h atoms
per 14 grams of ch2
groups, because you only
see h2 groups in there.
S two h atoms.
And then, if we're going
to try to keep moles here,
we need 6 times 10 to
the 23rd atoms per mole.
All right, and this
is centimeters cubed,
but this one has
leaders, so I need 10
to the 3 centimeters
cubed [INAUDIBLE]..
So again, verifying what your
high school teacher taught you,
that the first thing
is to learn units.
[INAUDIBLE]
So we take all these numbers.
This is the RH,
and this is the k.
And we can multiply
them all together,
and we should get something
reasonable, maybe.
And since we have MATLAB we
can make it do it for us.
So let's just do that.
So I think it's--
you have to help me, I
can't read this very well.
1ea star exponential,
[INAUDIBLE] 15,000,
slash 1.987 times--
what's body temperature?
40ec you told me?
So it's 310 Kelvin maybe--
times all these
numbers, 0.8 times 2.
Divide by 10 to the 23rd.
More factors in there.
OK, so 5 times 10
to the minus 25.
We think we got this right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: But
I want to get moles,
because I have this in moles--
it's [INAUDIBLE].
Three times mole
[INAUDIBLE] This
is really mole of
[INAUDIBLE] atoms.
OK, so we'll try and
see what happens.
So 5 times 7 minus 25.
It does seem pretty small,
so we have a problem.
And then the last reaction--
those reactions are typically
10 to the fifth, liters per mole
second.
This is for a recombination
of peroxy radicals.
So now, we have to get
rid of the volume unit.
This is for roo--
sorry, [INAUDIBLE] Yeah?
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: One
mole per [INAUDIBLE]..
Very good-- that's right,
because [INAUDIBLE] that's
just two atoms.
It's actually two moles.
Yes?
That would change
the [INAUDIBLE]
Only a factor of 10 to the 23rd.
So we'll get back.
Thank you.
Area 0.3, somewhere like it.
OK, so now let's go
do the same thing
with this one, ro plus roo.
So typically these reactions,
the normal way they're written
are numbers that are about 10
to 5th meters per mole second,
for two radicals recombining.
So now, I need to figure out how
can I change the volume here.
And the thing that is key
is that I know the volume
of this lipid particle.
So what I really want is this.
My k4 is going to be
equal to normal k, divided
by the volume of the
reactor, because the rate we
would write normally,
which would be droodt--
it would be like
negative 2k roo plus roo,
times the moles, the
concentration of roo squared.
This how we would
normally write it.
And so we have to have the--
this unit is all right.
So this is the volume
of the reactor.
So we were having
nroo over v, so we
might need Avogadro's number
over here, because the rate
here is in moles.
But now, we are going
to do single molecules.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you ever actually
use k4 in calculations?
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Yeah, for a.
I think an a is there.
Good question.
All right, so we
think this should
be like a volume per
molecule or something
like that, for one molecule.
So this should be
k4, should be 10
to the 5th, meters
per mole second,
divided by 4/3 pi r cubed.
And then, we need a mole--
[INAUDIBLE] 23rd molecules.
And we're gonna
have to make sure
that the leaders and
these guys match up,
which is not going
to be so easy.
You might use 10 to
the minus 6 meters.
This is going to
be meters cubed,
so I need 10 to the 3
liters per liter cubed.
And I think that will all
work out to be per second.
So let's try it.
So this would be 10 to the
5th over 4/3 pi is about 4--
10 to the negative 18,
6 times 10 to the 23rd.
So all the big ones cancel
each other out, is a 1 over 24.
Oh, I lost it.
That's bad.
OK, so one over 24,000.
It's a lot easier to
do with a lot of people
checking your work.
All right, so four
times n minus 5.
So this is what we think k is.
Anything else we need.
We need a t-max, you
want to guess the time?
You want to wait?
The time for the main
reaction, the time constant
is like seconds, right?
So if we made 1,000
seconds, a lot of stuff
is going to happen, right?
So maybe 1,000 seconds
will be OK for t-max.
So let's try this all.
Where's the main function.
The main function--
[INAUDIBLE] my n
initial was simple 1, 0.
And k, which was decided was 1e
minus 5, [INAUDIBLE],, 2.3, 4e,
25.
Now, if you just look at
these rates for a second,
I think you can see a
problem we're going to have.
How many steps are
we going to do?
I don't know.
10,000.
The time scales here--
this 27 is pretty fast.
So the stuff is going
to diffuse out of there,
because it's going to
disappear, and then nothing
is gonna happen.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Centimeters
squared, I thought so, yeah.
Thank you, so we think
this is 10 to the minus 9.
So this is actually [INAUDIBLE]
lower, is that right?
We're still gonna
have a problem.
But it's not quite bad
[INAUDIBLE] problem.
So let's fix that.
Um, so I think our problem
is that the 1e minus 5
is actually too slow.
So radicals are diffusing in
from outside at some rate,
and it's got to be a
rate so that if there
was no reaction, basically,
the concentrations of the stuff
here and here might be about the
same, same order of magnitude,
of the stuff that dissolved
in the water, dissolved
in the lipid.
Maybe a couple of
[INAUDIBLE] are different,
but not a million
times different.
And so we need to have the
rate of this stuff coming in
to be something
reasonable, that's
going to be consistent with
having a chance of having
some radical in there.
So now we to guess what we
think the real outside world
radical concentration is.
So maybe-- I don't know, what?
1e minus 10 moles per liter?
1e minus 6 moles per liter?
I don't know.
Any biologists here?
Do you know how many free
radicals you have in your body?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: They
can measure it, right?
So it can't be zero.
People talk about
reactive oxygen species
in your body, ROS.
Yes, so I don't know what it
is, 10 to the minus 6, maybe--
10 to the minus 8.
So we had the number for--
1e3 e3 is for going
out from the--
we have that rate leaving is
1e3 per second times the number
in there divided by
the volume, really.
Well, it's times the number,
that's the rate that's leaving.
But we would think
of this as a k.
I don't know how to
think of this, actually.
But for sure, the
volume matters.
So in order for us to compute
this, we use the r squared.
Now, another way you
look at this is say well,
is diffusion times the
gradient in the concentration?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: [INAUDIBLE]
Well, it's OK.
They would live in their little
tiny thing for a millisecond,
and then they diffuse out.
I think that actually
sounds very reasonable.
It's only a micron.
It's a very tiny, little thing.
So the question is how do
we complete the reverse?
So if we have stuff outside, and
suppose we didn't have anything
inside, we'd have some rate
of diffusion of the radical
from the outside coming in.
How do we think about it?
It's really got to be
the inverse of this.
So if we think the
time constant is
10 to the minus 3-- a
millisecond to come out,
it's probably about a
millisecond to come in.
I don't know.
You think it's got to maintain
whatever initial concentration
we put there, one
per volume, then
it's got to be about the same.
So this can't be as tiny
as 10 to the minus 5.
So if we take the average
concentration as one,
then this should 10
to the 3, I think.
If we think the average
concentration is 10,
then it should be 10 to the 4.
If we think the average
concentration this 100,
then it should be
10 to the five.
So let's try 10 to the 3.
So every millisecond,
something comes in or goes out,
some radical comes in and out.
You guys buy this?
Would you defend
this to your boss?
You can blame it
on Professor Green.
All right, here goes nothing.
Do you think it's going to work?
[LAUGHTER]
Aww, aww, line 29.
What's wrong?
What's wrong with that?
Parentheses off?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Maybe I
didn't save the latest version,
let's try again.
Ah, I didn't say
the latest version.
That's what it is.
Now, here goes nothing.
That [INAUDIBLE] help.
Leave me alone.
All right, trajectory,
the first column
is the times, so
it uses the x-axis.
And the last column is the
oxidation, the products.
So let's see if anything
peroxidized or not.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Oh, it should
have all the zeros, right?
So how can we do it when
we [INAUDIBLE] that way.
That's really weird.
Try it again.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: The
time is 2 plus tau.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM GREEN JR: I guess if
you look at the [INAUDIBLE] So
trajectory--
so it only [INAUDIBLE] 2 points.
That's why it looks like that.
I don't know why it
doesn't show the zeros.
Maybe they'll show on
top of the origin there.
So why did it only
give us two points?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Yeah, also--
seems like a 307 oxidations,
but why 307 all of a sudden?
That makes no sense, right--
because it should
be one at a time.
I should be seeing one
at a time coming in.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Yes,
it's very worrying.
I agree, so we have a bug.
So where is our bug.
This is where I need your help.
OK guys, let's figure
out why didn't this work.
So I'm storing-- by stepping
the steps, they're going up.
Ah, I know what's wrong.
I need this step thing
inside the loop here.
So all of this--
so let's see if I
can explain this.
I'm storing them
according to the step,
but right now, the wild
loop is just zipping around,
and then, it ends at the
step and just gets one.
So I'd rather start again.
It's gonna work this time?
You guys don't have any faith.
If people say that scientists
and engineers don't
have any faith, I think we have
more faith than anybody else.
We believe stuff like
this is going to work.
It's doing something now.
Who knows what?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Yup?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
time until your arrival
time, 7:15 [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: [INAUDIBLE]
is, not good, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Yeah,
it's a very good point.
I have a nested loop that
should not be, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
You don't necessarily
want to sample
every arrival time.
You might want to
sample [INAUDIBLE]
So you might want to have two.
You don't necessarily want
to [INAUDIBLE] every single--
WILLIAM GREEN JR:
Yes, yes, I agree.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: OK, so
let's see how we can fix this.
So we really want-- is
it really a jump out?
If the number of
steps gets too large,
we just want to jump
out, so we want to go to?
What do you think?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Break,
that's what we want.
So while is not the
correct thing to do here.
AUDIENCE: Why would
t [INAUDIBLE]..
WILLIAM GREEN JR: So
we're stepping time,
every time we'll do the steps.
And we just want a break.
[INAUDIBLE] step
greater than max steps.
AUDIENCE: Why don't you do it
with a while loop [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR:
What happens if you
do a wild loop like that?
Do you guys know?
Does it work?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: It'll work.
OK, that's easy.
Double and-- I tired it
with and this morning.
It didn't work, so that's
why I stopped doing it.
Stuff like that will
kill you, doesn't it?
All right, we gotta get rid
of one of the ends at the end.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: I think it's
likely to cause a problem,
why it's taking
10 million years.
So really, is there a reason it
should be nested loop, right?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR:
All right, try again.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM GREEN JR:
That's too fast.
Try that again.
That's not good.
See we have a [INAUDIBLE] here.
AUDIENCE: Oh no.
WILLIAM GREEN JR:
Oh, jumps to one.
That doesn't look very good.
Try that again.
Boom.
AUDIENCE: Oh!
WILLIAM GREEN JR: Oh, that
was pretty interesting, so
much more like what you expect,
so that at some time steps,
I have one, two, three,
or four, or five radicals
in this vesicle.
I only have one time
separate because of the nine.
So I think this actually
looks like what I expect.
I should see it jumping up and
down, stuff goes in and out,
sometimes it reacts,
sometimes it goes away.
So this one is correct.
I don't know what's
happened with the other one.
So I'll have to
figure out what's
wrong with that equation.
All right, we're
almost done time.
Well, I want to talk about
for just one minute is--
what are we gonna do after
we have this working?
So we get this working,
we have the trajectory,
we really want to run
10,000 trajectories,
because all we're doing is
sampling from the probability,
just the distribution of time.
So we need to run
zillions of them.
So this whole
thing we just wrote
would be inside a loop that
runs a lot of different cases,
because every time you run
this, because the random number,
you're going to get a
different trajectory.
And what you care about is
some kind of average behavior.
Or you might want to know
what's the percentage
chance that I'm going to have
[INAUDIBLE] oxidized and die?
So you might say I
want to count what
fraction of the
trajectories end up
with number of peroxide
greater than some number, that
means I'm dead.
And if that probability
is too high,
then I know I'm in big trouble.
So that'd be one possible thing.
You might have whatever
objective function you want,
but you need to run a lot to get
good statistics for anything.
So you're gonna have to
embed this whole calculation
inside a loop, and
then, you're going
to get a zillion of
these trajectories out.
And you figure out how are you
going to analyze them in order
to figure out what you want?
So one way is if you could
add the trajectories up--
so I have a trajectory--
suppose I have the
number roh's versus time.
And I do it once,
and I have none.
Then I have one, and then I have
two, and then, I wait longer,
and I get three.
And then, I wait
longer, I get four.
Whatever, something like that.
That's what it really looks
like for one trajectory.
And then, the next
time I run it,
it starts in a slightly
different time.
And this time it runs longer
before something else happens.
And then, it gets here, and
then maybe, it goes over here.
And I have a lot
of them like that.
I have 10,000 trajectories,
all look like that.
So if I could add them,
then I can do an average,
to get an average
trajectory, so that
would be one possible thing.
Or I might want to histogram,
so I might pick one time point.
So like after 20 minutes,
I want a histogram
of what this looks
like here or here.
One of them has four
peroxides, and one of them
has five peroxides.
And then the other 9,999--
some of the three,
some of the whatever.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
you're not gonna get
the same time points--
WILLIAM GREEN JR: You're not
going to get the same time
points, that's right.
So see the first
time it stopped,
the first time point was here,
the second time, the first time
point was here.
And they'll all be different.
So one is I was asking
a few of the students
before the class
started, there's
got to be a program
in MATLAB that
will let you generate these kind
of plots with the flat lines.
Or even a linear
interpolation would be OK too.
But you need to have
some way to add them up
as continuous functions,
because they all
have different time points.
So that's one practical
issue about it,
because you want to pick some
special time you care about,
and you want to know what
does the trajectory say,
what does this trajectory say?
But you actually only
have numbers here,
just really you have that
number and this number
and this number.
That's all you got.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You can plot
like a-- an out of time
to get to n amount of roh's and
then, that would be [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN JR: OK, so
then you plot [INAUDIBLE]
versus time instead,
that's right.
So that you just think
of what you want.
You're going to have all
this trajectory information.
And then you need to figure
out what do you want, and then,
what are you going to plot?
And what are you
trying to compute?
And you might want to
compute not only the number
but the standard deviation of
that number, because you don't
know how many
trajectories you have
to run before the
center of deviation
is narrow enough that
you'll be confident with it.
So this is a general problem
with this whole approach--
is that what you're
getting out are just
samples of things that happen.
It's just like if you
were doing a Monte Carlo,
and you just got some
of the energy values
from the hydrogen peroxide
calculation you guys did,
you have 47 of
those energy values.
What are you going
to do with that?
So you have to
figure out, how are
you going to take
the [INAUDIBLE]
of this calculation.
It's sampling from the real
solution, so it should be OK.
But what is it?
How are you going to handle
that and use it as a means--
it's sort of like as if you
ran a zillion experiments,
and then, what would you
do with all that data?
So that's like issue number one.
Now alternatively, you can
rewrite this as the master
equation and solve it as
an ODE, in which case,
you'll get explicitly p
of each of these ends.
So n rad, nroh time--
it would be continuous
in principle,
but actually, the
ODE solver gives you
out random time points also.
So you get a similar kind of
thing out from the ODE solver,
except it'll give
you probability
for every possible
range of these guys.
So if you have one radical, two
radicals, three radicals, four
radical, fie radicals,
and number of peroxides
from one to 1,000, or however
many peroxides you get,
you're going to get numbers.
So you have all these numbers,
all these probabilities,
at different times.
Again, what are you
going to do with that?
So one thing people do a
lot is they would plot, say,
the number of roh's versus time.
So at different time
points, compute the average
over all your trajectories.
Were with, if you
had this solution,
you can compute that
as nrooh, p, nrooh.
So like this, you're gonna
have some kind of average
if you do it that way.
And either one are fine, but you
have to think of what you want,
and then in both cases,
you'll probably be
interested in the dispersion.
So you [INAUDIBLE] want to
worry about the n squared too.
We'll talk more
about this on Monday.
All right and I posted
a homework problem
that was given last year
about this, for Kinetic Monte
Carlo for catalysis.
It's used a lot in
heterogeneous catalysis.
And if you have extra time,
feel free to do the problem.
It's a really good problem.
Those of you who are
feeling like you don't have
any extra time, and you're
about to kill yourself, please
don't kill yourself.
And instead, just
send an email to me
or Professor Swan
asking for an extension.
And we can give
you some more time
to finish up the homeworks
that's due tonight.
All right, talk to you
later.